It's September 19th, and as many of you ought to know, today is Talk like a Pirate Day.
For most of us land lovers, it's been a year or more since we spoke properly,...
...so here are a few simple suggestions that can help make you the toast of the crew.
Start with simple word replacement,...
...changing the following words in your vocabulary:...
..."My" to "me", "you" to "ye",...
..."I am", "you are", "he is", "she is" to "I be", "you be", "he be", "she be",...
..."yes" and "yeah" to "aye", "hello" and "hey" to "ahoy", "of" to "o'"...
...and "buddy" or "friend" to "matey" or "me hartey".
Throw in a gravelly, chain-smoker voice,...
...and it will change mundane everyday things like,...
..."Hey buddy, how are you?" into the pirate worthy, "Ahoy matey, how be ye?"
Now, squinting and contorting your face doesn't really help you speak pirate any better,...
...but it may help you feel the part...
...and make the whole experience more believable for others.
Another important aspect to talking like a pirate is "argh".
Surprise, delight, anger, lust, "argh" can pretty much fit any emotion,...
...but you might want to practice in front of the mirror to get your pirate face just right.
You see, the meaning of "argh" is determined...
...almost entirely by context and facial expression.
Also, try using the word "treasure" when discussing anything of value.
Old school pirates called it "booty",...
...but ordering someone to give up their "booty" can be a little questionable in mixed company.
If you need safer words for "treasure",...
...try "swag", "coin", "plunder", "pieces of eight", "doubloons" or "cargo".
Down in the hold, we've left ye a treasure trove of piratey things to say.
Here's a taste of them.
Heave to and prepare to be boarded.
Rattle me bones, avast ye swabs.
Look lively, ship shape, big as a whale.
Not worth but two bits, weather the Lizard.
That's it, flibber your gibbets and have a happy Talk like a Pirate Day.